There's a lot of interesting new
technology that scrubs job descriptions
for gendered words because the layer,
literally the ways that companies are
presenting opportunities is screening
out women are self screening out because
they're seeing words that they don't
relate to,
uh,
resonate.
Absolutely.
So there's literally like technology is
going to have to help us shortcut our
biases because we are so unfortunately
kind of hopeless when it comes to.
It's true with me,
it's really hard wired into us to be
biased against maybe ourselves and
believing the stereotypes we hear,
uh,
but then also particularly bias coming
out us of course,
from folks who have not done the work
around,
you know,
their own choices.
Right?
Getting us into boxes.
So I want to know from you,
so when you experienced in your career,
maybe some stereotype threat and how did
you correct for it?
When you know that it may be being
applied to Ya,
how do you not get swamped by that?
It's like the death by a thousand cuts,
you know,
it's,
it does accumulate and then it causes a
lot of us frankly,
to leave organizations.
Absolutely.
Like we don't even,
we can't even put a death,
a fine point on it,
but we feel,
don't feel valued and heard and
welcomed.
Right?
So how did you overcome that and kind of
claim your power and.
Yeah,
that's in line with a question.
Um,
so first by way of background as a
professor at Columbia and the first
African American to ever be tenured in
the sciences since,
you know,
since,
since Columbia started,
so that says a lot.
So that says,
I think it's incredible achievement,
but also says a lot about,
about,
uh,
about even where,
where we are today because people think
I don't struggle.
I struggle every single day.
I have perfectionistic syndrome where I
work on an article for a year and then I
work on it for another year and I know
the literature that women are more
likely to do that,
that perfectionistic syndrome is linked
to being worried about being
stereotyped.
I,
um,
make lots of decisions where,
where I,
I think very carefully about how I am
perceived by others.
And oftentimes I'll be in say a faculty
meeting or even when I'm talking to
companies and senior leaders and I'm
like,
well,
how many common should I make about race
versus gender versus religion?
Like am I being seen as too this or too
that.
So I worry about these things all the
time.
But a couple of things I know to be
true.
One is that when you take calculated
risks,
you know,
and you of put yourself a little bit out
there,
almost always something amazing happens.
And so that is one thing that I've
learned to.
I really believe that the whole
diversity and inclusion architecture,
people don't understand the underlying
science and when they understand that
it's not about bad people doing bad
things,
but about these structural differences,
it sort of gives me hope.
And that helps me take these calculated
risks.
And I think the third thing is just me
personally knowing like I will feel
anxiety every time I sit down to write a
paper and I go,
I'm the first African American tenured
in the sciences.
This has got to be really good.
You know,
this has to be like great,
like what does,
what,
what do I,
what do I do?
Whenever I think about that,
I understand that that's coming partly
from an environment where there's lots
of stereotypes.
Just knowing that sort of helps me kind
of take a little bit off in terms of
anxiety,
but it's something that I still work
through everyday and it's something that
I work with senior leaders to help
eliminate that.
When you see underperformance.
So in my field,
it's how many articles are you writing a
year,
but in the corporate world it might be
how many dollars are you bringing in or
how many clients are you going to see or
what your investment portfolio looks
like.
What I tell people is that
underperformance is,
doesn't mean that you can't do it.
It might be something else that maybe
there's something about the structure.
So,
but you must have the same at least
kinds of experiences.
I love to do.
I think that perfectionism is gendered.
Uh,
yes.
And,
and if I were a person of color,
I'd have it even worse because I think
when you're the only,
there's so much pressure on your
shoulders and this is the problem with
the demographics as we see them in many
companies are particularly at the senior
level when you are the only,
there is just an undue amount of
performance expectations.
It feels riskier because
you're at that table like clinging to
something that you've achieved and that
you are the first.
Yes.
And so I think that it's double work,
as you said earlier,
and triple work to not only be
proficient and excellent,
but to be managing,
am I safe here?
Am I welcomed here,
my valued here?
Am I a token?
Yes.
You know,
all of those things that go through our
heads and so that's why I loved your
comment about like who has supported you
to help you believe not only do you
belong here,
but that you know you're,
you're a star and there are many stars
behind you.
You know that you're actually paving the
way for.
I know in so much of my work with,
with lower level employees or early in
career seeing leaders like you who did
make it,
just that the,
the power of being able to see yourself
reflected in someone who's achieved and
who is the first is.
So it is one of those things that I
think leaders don't understand their
role models every single day.
Everything you do.
Absolutely.
And the fact that you rather a lot.
You're your,
uh,
thank you.
I appreciate that.
Um,
so I remember early on in my career,
and this is something that when I worked
with earlier,
early career employees,
I also talked to them about.
I used to ask people for feedback
constantly and I would go find the
person who I knew was going to be the
most critical and I would say tell me
about my work even though I was really
fearful.
So fast forward,
I've done research over the past 15
years showing that people with some kind
of outsider status are less likely to
receive informal feedback.
So everyone received formal feedback,
which is,
you know,
at the end of the year or you're mid
career,
your mid year review,
but the watercooler feedback,
which is I really matters what really
matters.
Like,
Hey,
I think that you should be doing this,
or hey,
have you thought about this or hey,
this new something or other came out and
you should do this or hey,
you probably didn't pull it together the
way you should have,
but you know,
come back the next day.
That informal feedback is really what
sort of pushes people in one and when
one direction or another.
And so there,
there are all of these subtle.
So the way I always think about it is
what is the structure of the company
that either gives rise or facilitate
stereotypes and really unconscious ways,
or what is the company doing to mitigate
those stereotypes.
And that is all at a very unconscious
level.
Mm.